alright Michael B Jordan you can
officially delete Fantastic Four from
your IMDB we don't even remember that
you were in that movie it's gone you
have washed it from your career you have
earned that from us
Creed so Creed is a movie it's in the
rocky universe it's not really a rocky
sequel but you can kind of see the rock
is able it follows the illegitimate love
child of Apollo Creed Apollo Creed died
before this kid was born he never knew
his dad and he's driven to fight so
that's what he wants to do so he tracks
down rocky to train him so he can be a
fighter that is like the commercial
bright cliffnotes of the movie really a
lot more going on in this movie than
just that if you go into this movie ler
all right get the Bob Brown we're gonna
watch a fight movie 3 they're gonna be
really pissed or just remarkably
disappointed because it's really not
like that this movie recaptures the
spirit of the original rocky without
ripping it off well first of all I love
the character of Donnie played by
Michael B Jordan
I just thought as a character he was
great as a human being he's great he
wants to make his own mark in the world
without riding the coattails of his
father's name and in essence you look at
the movie that's just what the movie is
doing this movie fights to make its own
place in cinema without riding the
coattails of the rocky name and just
like Michael B Jordan in the movie there
is a lesson of you are Apollo Creed's
son so use the name but fight to be your
own man and this movie obviously doesn't
run from the fact that it is in the
rocky universe we rocky played by
Sylvester Stallone trains this kid but
it does leave its own legacy I just
thought it was a great parallel Michael
B Jordan did a great job in this movie
this dude gets better and better and
better s he's in movies it's just great
to see that I mean he was one of the
kids in the wire and I didn't really
think anything of him and now he is
Michael B Jordan and he's just here to
stay
got to talk about this dude though
Sylvester Stallone holy at a point
I thought and I believe a lot of us
thought this was like Oh Sylvester
Stallone you're kind of a cartoon
version of the action star you used to
be in you're in expendable movies now
and that's just kind of what you're
gonna do until you're like I am done
with Hollywood oh but no we were all
wrong I don't think Sylvester Stallone
knew he was capable of this anymore
so Lester Stallone delivers such a great
performance in this movie this is a
Sylvester Stallone we thought was buried
years ago I can guarantee now his agent
is brushing off all of this
action movie scripts off of his desk and
they're now replaced with dramas like a
sly you can do this now now the world
knows it too the fights were exciting in
this movie the movie doesn't rely on the
fights but they don't waste anything on
the fight the end fight of this movie
for me though wasn't as exciting as
another fight that happens in this movie
where I'm like oh my god this is one
take I don't think it was actually one
take there are moments if you edit you
know what you're looking for where
you're like hey that's where an edit
could have been but that's not the point
the point is they do it in a way where
it looks like one shot he starts taking
damage his eye starts bleeding you're
like I can't see where they could have
just slapped the makeup on him and what
ran offset without being seen so it just
makes it so real looking and in the end
I thought Creed was fantastic it's not
always this exciting movie but that's
not why you should be here it's a great
character movie about this young man who
has never had a place in the world who
wants to forge his own place in the
world in an old man who was a rival of
his father who became a friend of his
father and together they find a family
among themselves and it's a testament to
greatness and knowing that greatness
comes from in here it's a touching movie
and I was tearing up by the end can't
deny that and I will say Creed is
awesome tacular
Creed has done what I hope Star Wars The
Force awakens does but just ultimately
be a new installment in a franchise that
goes back decades back to the 70s so
recaptures the spirit of the first one
the spirit of what made it great and you
bring it home for a whole new generation
to enjoy Creed has done that
I thought Star Wars does it do I guess
so Creed have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more